oh [ __ ] Monday night oh [ __ ] that's all
I got to say right
uncle Joey coming at you Monday night we
are everything tonight we got red velvet
cookies
we got TKOs we got more tea chaos we got
more TKOs and we got more details we got
stars we are everything so tonight you
choose the great night to come and watch
we got great guests we got great
everything but what I got a [ __ ] around
we're gonna get right to the [ __ ]
periodicals here we're gonna open up
with three of these right here cuz ain't
no looking back the special dollar day
no looking back people always remember
that they no coming back I don't give a
[ __ ] what you do you think about all I
love my girlfriend in high school too
late [ __ ] there's no more high
school she's blowin somebody else now
you're on to bigger and better things my
point you can't go back you understand
me we're going deep tonight mainly we
got it with doing two and a half of
these we got a 250 milligrams red velvet
cookie look at this [ __ ] tonight TKO for
everybody this is like GSB giving up
backhand understand me [ __ ] everything
tell Bobby Charlotte to have nothing
look at this four squares bam bam we
inhale each one of those [ __ ]
why they usually give you instructions
but here at the church we don't need
[ __ ] instructions cuz we don't cut
them in half you see I'm saying cut them
in half as [ __ ] we just call like
this you like that jelly thing you ever
go to a restaurant you get those jelly
things you pop this out like this
oh my god it's all t8z and gooey look at
this look at this you saw gooey and [ __ ]
but I am like a [ __ ] magician and
since we're gonna do two of these time
one for me I want Polly look at this oh
my goodness
oh my god I wish you mother
it's like taking the guts out of the THC
man you know I'm saying
that's number one for me and number two
fully understand shortly
I just am the half all done so we do the
whole [ __ ] thing tonight we should
just do all four of these [ __ ] things
oh look at that gooey disgust stars of
death - coming tomorrow [ __ ] never
beware we're just [ __ ] experimenting
with different debts goal ego [ __ ]
we got a little flow tonight we got some
[ __ ] fairies oh gee this is the [ __ ]
they [ __ ] smoke before they got shot
in Paris and that sick [ __ ] look
at this what's this Joey what is this
[ __ ] thing this right here my friends
is turnt
if this [ __ ] thing tonight don't kill
me this cookie will you understand they
give you like a seal to seal it back up
but we're all in one chunk here please
making funny noises oh my God look at
this THC cookie of debt
wait you got more water
don't know what means don't do a [ __ ]
that's a good thing about it you get
high on the oedipal thing that eat
something you got a cookie without big
bite Lee not little fatty bites one big
well that's a [ __ ] bite well another
one you're breaking a cookie let's go
we're in training that's a little bite
see you gotta get a bigger now let you
[ __ ] slide yeah I got a big bite here
that's it that's a big bite in hell that
[ __ ] thing trying to [ __ ] a
bullshitter in [ __ ] it's as if people
you wanna I missed you we haven't done a
podcast as last Wednesday I gotta tell
you something we'll save this for later
for the munchies Lee's having a good old
time a little funk it's now and we still
got another pack of rubber to go time
we're going deep to that people I don't
give a [ __ ] with your plans are I don't
give a [ __ ] what you're through tomorrow
cancel them now cuz the Church of what's
happened now is in full [ __ ]
effect we got the music we got the
reefer we got the bondage leaves
finishing up the cookie delicious
delicious and nutritious look at that
like a [ __ ] honey Molly and gonna
scoop that up to this your little crumbs
can't leave that for the mouth you'll
kill him with that [ __ ] tougher than
dead people now is the bong hit portion
of my show what the [ __ ] you gonna do
with your life be happy stop that I used
to ask myself that [ __ ] all the time
when I was 20 21 22 28 35 what am I
gonna do with my life well I didn't do
dick we're here we're having a good time
and sometimes you gotta have a good time
that's what comes first
we fill this [ __ ] bong at that dump
it
please don't chew in the cookie you can
sell as well I'll have to stab you [ __ ]
the sand Sunfire but with this periscope
like this why not cuz they're [ __ ]
home scared let me tell you something I
wish I was still doing more like the
[ __ ] 80s I've been doing bar on
periscope
you [ __ ] we shooting yourselves
as [ __ ] then have [ __ ] things looking
for me all over the place every night
have to stop with different mention
that's
with the is this this tastes even better
[ __ ]
I'm happy you join this tonight great
week we'll have to talk about got a big
week this week ladies and gentlemen not
me you you always have a big week me I'm
a [ __ ] bum and I'm not going on I'm
on vacation week this week I got a few
calls to make
I'm gonna babysit my wife's going out on
the do few podcast with my man Lee went
to the chiropractor for all that fun
[ __ ] we'll talk about it during the show
right now it's time for bondage Joe
you're out early in the [ __ ] chitchat
you want to chitchat
join us chitchat line alright you ain't
got no respect I'm saying cuz you kick
me when I'm down
who kicks me when I'm down [ __ ]
Joe three oh [ __ ]
well he's over there giggling having a
shuttle up having a good [ __ ] time
see you ready for these bunk it's a debt
I hope you guys are bonding it up over
there remember as always if you 18 get
off the [ __ ] periscope cop something
I don't want you doing [ __ ] and your mom
has to call me I don't know what my
son's doing these these beneath the red
stars of death talk about Jewish talk
about Jewish people talking about Jewish
people
here we go Lee is the jam that [ __ ]
started off here we go Saturday night
[ __ ] get this meal
there we go there we go
Islam talking about and training the
[ __ ] me the [ __ ] and dodges look at
the muscles and everything let's go oh
yeah there's always me what you think
you're dealing with it there's always
more like some black time you like it to
give you the full [ __ ] patois they go
sucked down in there you go there you go
that's on two legs the training is
paying off ladies and gentlemen he's not
spitting out lungs he's a regular
[ __ ] town tonight happy aren't you
[ __ ] them happy cops now we clean this
in here somebody [ __ ] spit in here
they not you I think it was that Savage
we had earlier
ah and you thought you were safe huh
nobody's safe when uncle Joey's around
doing pocket
we got one TKO with populist a few
minutes we're going deep tonight when I
come here tomorrow at 2:00 we'll be
under a [ __ ] tent going what the [ __ ]
happened last night Joey we blacked out
tonight we have potential for THC
blackouts you understand me so ready for
bed
oh no easy training never would have
meditate thinking about his life no way
he went wrong he should've got a masters
at Emerson you could stay for your
masters you were never met me as she was
still been [ __ ] to learn to it to how to
[ __ ] do a wire with the [ __ ] here you
learn more here in two years then you
fill it with any what's happening you
bad [ __ ] just checking in with
you making sure you straight you did
your goals tonight we've been your
twenty two push-ups for the [ __ ] dead
Marines whatever you set up sir whatever
you do whatever you could do I stretched
I did some push-ups I went to the
chiropractor got a massage my back will
be pulled up and hopefully ready to go
by [ __ ] Thursday you understand me
I'm back on the [ __ ] hunt that I died
I'm not stopping this time go to 65 I
look like [ __ ] that big country I
gotta stop looking like a bull Joey's
[ __ ] anyway
what are we doing here we talked and
we're doing Barbies we're under you know
me I'm a man of many [ __ ]
opportunities let's do a part of it what
the [ __ ]
when in doubt you gotta go with the
[ __ ] Martin okay don't give a [ __ ]
what they tell you always gonna go with
the bombing we'll try some of these
[ __ ] when we have yet flow Oh
we'll do some of the Spanish this palace
is tremendous time this with the
terrorists smoke before you shot
everybody isn't this [ __ ] right here
jack
trust me I almost shot a [ __ ]
today that's how I know weed everywhere
but we don't give a [ __ ] that's how we
got it here I don't want advice for you
[ __ ] one piece of advice it
goes by fast trust me
ah I just popular throw Paulo you ever
get us to a father being up for meeting
bad [ __ ] we're gonna throw up I'll
throw you spit out their yellow you
crush on like a pimple they smell funny
tremendous listen your throne you don't
pop it they come out of your throat
naturally oh and you squeezing they
smell like cat and [ __ ] pathetic
just like the inside of those dumplings
eat last week that's it
your waste searchin searchin and it's
easy come and easy go
it's easy come and easy go [ __ ] oh
I'm sorry but it's try them on son oh
you mean another heartache I eat mice
nuts I don't eat the [ __ ] throat
polyps let me tell you so let's clear
Frank I don't meet just any snap I got
to blow my nose neither [ __ ] it's not
that's disgusting but if you get one of
those good coast life that's standing
straight up it comes from up here when
you pluck it it feels like you plot the
[ __ ] eyebrows [ __ ] like equilibriums
off those nuts are delicious nutritious
and you put them back into the body it's
like it's like people drink this in the
morning eight miles nuts in one you take
those drag things out in the morning
forget about that put some maple syrup
on un-fuckin'-believable
I think it's time for a bonding will you
people think that yeah but Joey yo we're
talking me and making no [ __ ] sense
urease not some kind of individual it's
your turn you like be like mercy me time
me time all right
oh you like a candle tremendous solid
you understand me silent yeah just put
the fire out
let's put the fires this I do my turn oh
it's still burning isn't always burning
you can fire
look at you see that no more coughing
you to be successful with the bomb if
you take uncle Joey's 14 days to better
bond its course okay go to twitter.com
dot bong hit to death send 999 and you
too could learn how to have lungs of
steel within 14 [ __ ] days blow your
friends away go to a party be the life
of the party smoke coming out of your
nose it is and [ __ ] mean why your
friends got a smoke the vapor pen to get
that type of [ __ ] action but here you
[ __ ] above bong gets like this
two weeks uncle Joey's bonded training
we might have to start doing it on
periscope it's like a daily [ __ ]
class but two weeks just together be up
in tip-top Magoo I'll be the boss rootin
a bong hit long jump say that's right
either you be a master or your die
[ __ ] try all right
you bring it on the heartache
alright let's [ __ ] do this one more
ball we'll send you guys bon voyage II
and then we'll start this podcast what
time is 7:45 p.m. st. who's better than
you
7:45 you're sitting here with Uncle Joey
your cousin Lisa at you can't go from
the wrong he understand
mm-hmm that's it and that's that we're
gonna start your show off tonight
a little music a little conversation you
know how we do it people
yeah then are you [ __ ] out all right
you know I love you if you came to
Chicago this last weekend thank you very
much for supporting us Thursday Friday
Saturday from Matt Oh Maya whatever his
[ __ ] name is - my boy Josh Passini
over at 10th planet till my man old beat
the Greek over at the jujitsu [ __ ]
place he owns that's a bad [ __ ]
and all the other people I came people
came to the taping I love you Bob low
angus is doing a little interruption but
we're back [ __ ]
you know why we're back because that's
how we do it we might as well fill up
another [ __ ] bong bit because the
party's just starting our guest is here
and yeah that's it man
you know we're just trying to truck it
keep it alive you know I come to you
[ __ ] from the heart
the most truth who I can be is with you
[ __ ] from the podcast that's how
I wanna or no misunderstandings and
that's it that's it
hopefully I'll be back at YouTube my
Wednesday and I'm home I gotta let me
see where am I going the rest of the
year I'm going to Vegas Halloween right
then I go to Boston November 11th and
12th and Foxwoods on the November 12th
then we got [ __ ] in the Houston comedy
thing November 18th
and then we got her vine improv the
night before Thanksgiving it's sad
simple song I could do 4 5 - Gigi's a
week at the first week of [ __ ]
December in Portland Oregon I'm gonna go
visit my main man Chael Sonnen for a day
and that's it New Year's with Joe a
couple [ __ ] isolated dates and I said
you bad [ __ ] you know but Joey
loved me what you think should we do
another bond I think so too I think we
should switch this out longer to the
other side and do another pumpkin will
you [ __ ] let me drink a little water
Fred before I D hydrate here these
edible to start the [ __ ] and hit my
brain
one thing I like about stars
is that you get high quick like when you
take them they hit you right 10 minutes
but it's a soft finger up the ass
unless you've a bunch of make myself I'm
a [ __ ] gorilla I love the scars of
death but when I don't have them I ATT
chaos and they have a guarantee that
you're gonna get off with 260 [ __ ]
minutes
look at me right here this is no [ __ ]
can you see it right there 60 minute
guaran-fucking-tee you see that see that
6p [ __ ] minute can't beat that
that's what you need you know you're in
a tough situation you go to jail you
gotta go to court whatever the [ __ ]
going on and you pop one of these you go
in there nobody knows nothing and that's
what you want to do half the time
nobody knows nothing you know I don't
know I was walking by I saw this the
knife I was picking it up you know how
it is you don't know nothing I switch
this out you should do [ __ ] outlines
right one of my old gotta be in the top
[ __ ] five of me always Def Leppard on
top of their game and Def Leppard was so
on top of their game they're coming back
next [ __ ] year on the tour with
poison and they're doing commercials
didn't eat me and I have a family I
always had a feeling that's [ __ ] good
and we're back just like that do some
science we'll load up the bong
we'll do a bong galino - here we go
we've mastered bringing down the
heartbreak again I don't give a [ __ ]
with together as long as what to get out
the way I'll watch a movie at their time
I watch an episode of [ __ ] black
orange whatever the new black is the new
orange I do whatever the [ __ ] you you
know me I don't fall in love with that
key I sit here I sit here I sit at home
I play with the baby
I go to jujitsu I write stupid jokes now
to a star hot line in the book again
this last chat battery right so
hopefully we could sell the book and we
could get it out to you guys buy the
[ __ ] next caller that has that for
you what the [ __ ] is that
who's better than your uncle [ __ ]
Joey nobody waiting on Ralphie may leave
Lee Leland you know everybody's here
send lazaros here
look at his [ __ ] so I think should we do
another fungally know or what let's do
another bong hit this that's how we've
always known Sam make a [ __ ] Trump
doing bong hits with uncle Joey
great thing about that look at [ __ ]
Donald Trump light Donald Trump doing
bong hits with uncle Joey the [ __ ] is
battling me he gave me this in this
office he's like Joey I'm gonna get you
a party I'm gonna get you a Cuba and we
will do a bong hit with you I made this
[ __ ] wig curl you understand me
it's we right here Paris ogia almost
kill them you fill this up this way like
this
alright you pack this in like Benihana
put a shrimp on your head
I love you [ __ ] you know that see
in a couple minutes my main man is here
oh [ __ ] we'll see you in 10 minutes
[ __ ] stay black